today I was feeling quite nostalgic for
obvious reasons for America because I'm
a real nationalist now a few days ago
Fabiana Cara Juana your favorite player
and winner of the 2014 Sinquefield Cup
not the 2015 one that's for sure be
lucky to come in fourth what are the
three players that he might come and
fourth okay so if you if you kids all
make a lot of bets you bet on
Fabiana coming in last terrible anyway
he won last year so he used to be good
and uh he was the best player who played
for Italy and now he plays for the US
because he's American so now the United
States has three players the top ten in
the world Hikaru Nakamura your favorite
player
Fabiano Carolina who's now plays for the
US and Wesley so and they're all going
to play the Sinquefield Cup next month
even though it's not next month but it's
X months to you so I did good it's in
August in a little bit of September and
we had a lot of discussions about the
Sinquefield Cup
I was talking to Magnus and akaru and
the people who run the Chess Club and I
was like dudes my birthday September 6
and they're like alright alright
the Sinquefield couple ends September
5th ok so that way I get to celebrate my
birthday
ok now because I'm feeling like
nostalgic for America because Nakamura
is now the second rated player in the
world he just tied for second in Norway
we got three guys in the top 10 Walter
brown your favorite Grandmaster passed
away earlier this week he was one of the
best players the United States in the
late 60s 70s and 80s and he died very
young at the age of 66 I just saw him
last week so I was thinking I got to
show you something really American and
what's the most American chess player
ever the only one you've heard of who's
the only American chess player you've
heard of who's not me say it louder I
heard somebody say it
bobby fisher' very good good whispering
okay bobby fischer who is also the
craziest player who ever lived and I'm
talking to you steinitz that's right
well I was crazy in Stine it's it's
close okay he played what was called up
on my phone down for a lot of air quotes
here the game of the century K must have
been a slow century okay
now this game is very suspicious because
every move what white made was terrible
but that helped black win so that was
very nice of him now there were two
brothers who played chess last century
only two Robert Byrne and Donald Byrne
Robert Byrne was a candidate for the
World Championship and a fine tennis
player ladies not to use all right
Donald Byrne was an international master
and again about town and Donald Byrne
was white Bobby Fischer was black now
what will surprise you you ready to be
surprised
Bobby Fischer was only 13 years old when
this game was played and he played
several brilliant moves to win the game
including sacrificing his queen although
he has another famous game with Robert
Byrne which is better than this game but
okay anyway this is the game of the
century for those of you who have been
with the Chess Club
I need more air quotes and you've seen
the art on the wall I wish I could roll
my eyes better one of the art
installations actually shows this game
over and over and over again some day
I'll memorize the game okay so Fischer
was black Donald Byrne was white they
developed their Knights hooray - hoping
Knights is good okay c4 as you know c4
is right and back up about 20 feet thank
you okay now where did black move his
bishop this one nowhere so he was like
hey these pawns are blocking me so he
moved one of them you could move either
one if you moved them two squares then
White's going to take it and you'll cry
so he moved it one square he's going to
put his Bishop here now when my mom
plays chess she likes to play this move
too
but she can never remember which square
to go to and she flips the quite in her
head and goes to the wrong one okay
you want your Bishop here because that's
the longest diagonal ever and when your
Bishop goes here what do we call that
Bishop it as an Italian name it's what
kind of Bishop a fianchettoed Bishop
okay and that's what Fisher did even
though he was 13 he encountered his
bishop okay and now he's ready to castle
and white plate in the center now black
has two moves
one is the grünfeld with d5 that's the
name of the opening and one is the
King's Indian with castles and Fisher
likes to play both of them
he castled now if this game was played
today 95% of grandmasters would play in
the center but this game was played over
50 years ago so a white played here
actually I play that move myself
sometimes
now even though black didn't play the
Grunfeld last move he played at this
move he put his pawn in the middle could
have proves his pawn one square also
okay and white played Queen b3 attacking
this pawn eight million times
oh and I miscounted eight million in
four okay so three of whites pieces are
attacking this pawn so black took the
pawn this move is hard to find what did
white play very hard to find what do you
think takes you took the pawn right now
black center pawn is gone and so White's
going to big get a big center next to
move and now c6 is a funny move but this
game was played when Fischer was 13 so
I'll give him a break efore Knight bd7
which site has a better Center white or
black I'll give you one more guess I'll
give you one more guess white obviously
has a better Center White has two pawns
in the center black has nothing in the
center two pawns
Center is better than nothing right my
comer okay don't don't kill the children
not so class is over Thunder I'm up in
front all right who gets the prize for
getting teased the most will be you a
bit back up a lot yeah yeah more much
more okay now White has a better center
the black has two advantages black
castle and white didn't right and should
you move your queen out in the opening
or should you move your bishops and dice
Bishop's a knight but white already made
two Queen moves
how could he so white did two things
wrong and he did one thing right
he put his pawns in the middle but he
moved his Queen didn't castle so let's
see who wins because of all this now he
put his rook in the middle and black me
to move that every child will approve of
I don't approve of it but all of you
will you'd be like yeah that's a good
move because he was 13 so plays like you
do he played nine to be six I wonder why
he did that do you think White's going
to see his Queen attacked obviously now
black didn't play Knight b6 does it
attacks the Queen that just happened to
be the case black wanted to move out his
bishop but he couldn't move his bishop
because his knight was blocking him say
what is Knight out of the way white
being a fine player moved his Queen and
black up so black has two advantages
black has all of his minor pieces out
and white doesn't and black castled
and white didn't but white has a nice
Center okay now black white did
something that makes me furious I've
never been so angry so you better not do
this don't what I'm with that
don't do it why should say hey my
Knights pinned and my bishop didn't move
yet let's move our bishop and unpin our
knight and get ready to castle that's
what I would do in a one-minute game but
Donald Byrne is like way
a minute I already move this bishop
let's move it again
okay moved it here terrible
okay now Fisher was like wait a minute
you move this here then you move this
again you didn't castle he didn't get
your Bishop out I'm going to punish you
so he sent him to his room and he's like
I'm an adult in you're thirteen now
notice this Knight protects this pawn
because I said so
so if black takes the pawn white takes
the knight and says what are you doing
how so Fisher was like I have an idea
let's make this Knight move away then
I'll play Knight takes pawn
so what move did Fisher make to attack
this tonight a very strange move but he
did attack the knight you got to give
him that I did black attack this knight
Knight to white clothes
yeah but then then your knight couldn't
take this Punk as you moved your knight
Wow the other Knight to d5 where a pawn
could take it no what a world
yeah Knight where where a four nine a
four is what Fischer played attacking
the knight in the Queen wow what a
player okay so that was the first
brilliant move of the game now Donald
Byrne was like hmm if I take this Knight
and he takes my pawn now his Knights
forking my Queen and Bishop where can
white move his Queen where it still
protects his Bishop because he doesn't
want to lose his Queen he doesn't want
to lose his Bishop yeah that's a good
answer yeah yeah yeah
Queeny five is very risky because of
this bishop very risky right so let's
not go there scared there's two answers
I'm thinking of and one of those not
Arby's yes
the Queen's on c5 Queen b5 is slightly
risky because there's a pawn here so the
pawn would take you yeah queen c1 now
black has a triple fork
that's why burn didn't play this black
has a move that attacks the bishop the
knight and the King first black has to
take the bishop white takes the knight
now we can fork this night this night
and this King at the same time and that
crazy that's crazy talk it's so crazy
she runs out of breath she's like oh man
that's a great move how does black
attack these three things at once
well partial credit how about with the
Queen Queen a5 check attacking
everything and just in case the bishop
is attacking the rook so white has four
pieces attacked so Byrne said I'm not
doing that I don't want four pieces
attacked baby okay so instead of losing
all of his pieces after Knight a four
instead of playing nineteen tonight
Knight takes e4 and crying he just reads
treated his queen he's like whatever
okay even though that wasn't really
popular at that time all right
and then after Knight eighth eighth
Queen a three black took the night
that's why he played night a four okay
and then white said I'll take that and
finally the e4 pawn is not protected so
black took it
however this unleashes the latent
potential
the bishop if you had more than the
eighth-grade education you would
understand the difference between latent
potential and actualize potential but
you don't quote M retai too often in the
kids class not too often and not go to
jail so that was pretty good okay
9 take c4 and now White's like thank you
very much white was a very polite person
what's it called what this Bishop is
doing these guys for how come black
can't just take this bishop for free the
Queen really far away is protecting the
bishop okay so White's going to win some
material but White's King is still on a1
terrible okay so he saved his queen that
seems like a good piece to save and
instead of taking the rook he developed
his bishop so he could castle okay and
then Fischer said yum yum yum yum yum
I'll take that Knight takes c3 now most
of you are confused you're like why
doesn't he just take the knight now is
the queen protecting the bishop anymore
now so if I play rook to e8 pitting your
Bishop to your King you're going to be
very unhappy
okay so Byrne is like I have an idea I'm
going to take your knight but before I
take your knight
I'm going to save my bishop then I'll
take your Knight attack the Queen and
Fischer said check because it's check
did White Castle out of check if it's
legal he would have done it then white
would probably be winning but it's not
legal to castle when you're in check so
he just moved his King okay now you're
going to see the most famous move
possibly ever played ever it's one of
the five most famous moves in chests
notice white is attacking the Queen
and white is attacking the night so
white was pretty happy now okay and this
guy's like wait a minute I've seen this
game he's raising his hand you whether
you could cast a lot of check what's the
famous move Queen c2 that used to be on
my shirt who played Queen c2 somebody
yeah I forgot to okay now in this
position black played the amazing
retreat Bishop e6 totally ignoring his
queen and white said oh boy
I'm going to take your queen and he did
and then he lost all of his pieces but
he took a queen we're going to see how
in a second so let's look at not taking
the Queen let's pretend we take the
bishop now is there a white bishop there
anymore no
so black would play check notice how
it's check what would white do to get
out of check move back to e1 I mean I
don't know about that move then black
has the advantage because the game is
over right that's checkmate so I'll show
you a funnier checkmate white goes here
then we check them then we double check
them notice how the knight and the Queen
are attacking the King if the King goes
here Queen hear me now you're going to
see your favorite checkmate ever after
King here black has a to move checkmate
the first move is awesome did you see a
to move checkmate for black what's the
most awesome first move yeah
you're two-thirds right
yeah queen f1 notice how the knight
defends the Queen you agree so the rook
has to take and now checkmate wouldn't
it have been awesome
that's called smothered me okay me and I
can't make that joke because I actually
will get fired
yeah alright so how if I don't make the
job then you know you know should make
that job okay so instead of Bishop takes
e6 getting checkmated exactly Donald
Byrne is like oh boy a free Queen hooray
for me that's right so this bishop just
went here and he played Bishop takes
Bishop check now Fisher takes a piece
every move he's like oh boy I'm going to
take a lot of pieces Donald Byrne made
the only legal move then he got put in
shock then he made the only legal move
again
he's pretty good right makes the only
legal move does that rook on c1 or
what's on d1 okay I put it back on the
wrong square nine takes d4 check notice
how it's check because it's discovered
check right all right King back check
King back nine c3 check let's check King
back and now he played as mission Zhuge
instead of taking this rook he took this
bishop first and now the rook attacks
the Queen and the Knight attacks the
rook
okay so White's pieces are disappearing
he played Queen here and he's like you
take my rook and I'll take your bishop
that's fair and fishers like you can't
have my Bishop rook a for defending his
Bishop and the guys like all right I'll
take upon
and then fish is like
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum now let's do some
counting White has an extra queen
remember white took that Queen how many
extra pieces does black have who has
more rocks
we almost the whole chess set black has
two rocks and White has one rook they
have the same number of knights and
black has two bishops so black has an
extra ruck and two extra bishops now
we're going to vote okay you can pick
one of two you can pick an extra queen
or you can pick a rook and two bishops
which would you rather have who says a
queen who says a rook and two bishops
yeah rook and two bishops that's a lot
of pieces I look into bishops if you do
silly kids math the only math you know
how to do is worth eleven and then a
queen is worth nine eleven is more than
nine right so Rick and two bishops is
better than a queen coincidentally black
is also a head upon also that pawn is
not going to live too long is it also
the rook is trapped so White's position
is terrible
White's down material and his positions
bad so he got he lost pretty fast
now most grandmasters would resign they
say I give up because you're crushing me
but because he didn't resign we got to
see a good checkmate so it's good he
didn't resign good for us so he played
h3 so his King could escape his King
didn't escape true good and then black
went
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum took more pawns now
he's threatening this pawn with his
night in his rook the King escaped and
Fisher went nom-nom-nom-nom-nom
now black is up three pawn that's a lot
of pawns and then he escaped with his
rook and Fisher took the rook and his
opponent took the rook back
that's fair right actually he checked
him first and then he took the rope back
which doesn't make much of a difference
now black played in the middle eyeing
this pawn over here
the night went here and the night went
in the center boy Fischer is good at
playing in the center 94 Queen to b8 now
some of you are confused some of you you
were like wait a minute
doesn't this Bishop attack the Queen and
the king that looks good right but it's
not possible now because the Queen has
egg the king the Queen takes the bishop
I'd be pretty happy so the bishop is
pinned it can't move so Fischer's like
hey my pawns attack I'm going to save it
ok then they block their pawns up so
nobody could move their pawns that's
fair and Fischer really wanted to play
here but the Queen pens is bishop now
the Queen doesn't pin his Bishop now the
bishops going there now once again if
this game was played in the last five
years and two grandmasters were playing
white would have resigned a long time
ago but this game was played a long time
ago and Fischer was 13 years old his
opponent wasn't a grandmaster so they
played all the way to checkmate which is
what you guys do so black used 4 pieces
to checkmate Wyatt that wasn't very nice
of him every move was check and blacks
got four pieces so that's a lot of
checking right can you believe how much
he's getting checked are you shocked
look at all those checks look at all
that 4 black pieces are attacking the
king that's a lot of pieces right
wouldn't you be scared if you were white
ok now black has two moves that are
checkmate and Fischer played one of them
we find a move for black that's
checkmate checkmate is good because you
win if you play ninety to the king can
go here because your Knights not there
anymore
then you would win in three moves
instead of in one yeah
Bishop a3 is checkmate
that's pretty checkmate II and black
played another checkmate black played
another checkmate rook a one my king can
go up the board because your rook us
went down but you were 1/3 correct yeah
you got the rook part right rook c2
almost as good as the greatest whatever
Queen c2 I don't know that came from
rook see to check me notice black has
four pieces attacking White's King
White's got nothing black has three
extra pawns too so that game was pretty
good from black especially the move
Bishop to e6 that was a great move
however the best part was the fact that
black was 13 years old usually when
you're 13 you don't sacrifice your queen
and be international masters usually you
blunder your queen and then you resign
right and if I remember correctly that
was played in 1956 and that's correct I
didn't know was played October 17th you
learn something new every day
right and luckily for us grandmasters
who were good a hundred years ago and 80
years ago when we look at their games
we're like wow those grandmasters are
pretty good but nowadays when people are
grandmasters we can go back in time and
go hey look at that game he played when
he was seven he was terrible right so we
look at Fischer's games when Fischer was
12 13 14 years old
not quite as good when he was in his 20s
but still pretty good right okay
and so I have a lot of my games when I
was nine ten
I don't show you those games where I
give all my pieces away that ratings
1,400 I'll show you those okay so
because we have databases we can look at
chess games we can see how people got
better as time went by
maybe when magnus carlsen was seven he
didn't play very good now he's the best
maybe but we know now because we can
look at those games now he's read of
2950 so he plays pretty good just
kidding 2850 how silly can I be okay so
that was a great game from a great
American player and he was barely crazy
at the time but he still played pretty
well right and the crazier he got the
better he played I hope you've learned
something today